[Music]
girl can we talk about the fact that you
were having such serious great fashion
moments lately really yeah I found the
comfort here the shoes trousers I'm not
gonna flash my cookie anytime soon it's
a good day for me definitely
you looked also amazing at the game of
Thrones premiere and that's not just
because you brought your really
attractive boyfriend with you are you
forgetting accessory I've got a no is
Joe rooting for Sansa to end up on the
Iron Throne I don't know I don't know we
didn't talk about it um we love blush
are you oh god yeah or I'm sweaty I can
tell Sophie you look a little smitten
right now I don't know I'm smitten with
Maisie I'm smitten with Maisie chills my
wife can we talk about the fact that
Maisie is joining the Marvel verse just
like you if we don't get a crossover on
Game of Thrones getting one on x-men
okay that's really exclusive s she's
joining x-men New Mutants what advice do
you have for her to be joining this
brand-new franchise oh wow I mean she
kind of cooled me up the Davis she was
offered it and she was like what do I do
like what should I do and I was like
take it 100% it's gonna be the best
thing for you but my advice to her would
be like you feel like an idiot doing it
you're doing it right because being a
mutant you have to do the craziest like
[ __ ] your hands and transforming into
things and you feel like an idiot doing
it but it's gonna look awesome when it
comes out what's the CGI's in there it's
gonna be great mazing
you've got a new x-men movie coming out
right now what can you tease about your
journey
I can tease nothing really I really I
have like they're gonna kill me if I
tease anything well here's a question
for you who is more concerned about
secrets Game of Thrones or Marvel Oh God
both of them have like snipers on my
back right now I can't reveal anything
about either they're crazy
lockdown it's so lockdown but it's more
exciting for the fans that way right it
was really exciting for us to see Ed
Sheeran in the premiere that was such a
nice surprise one it's cuz Maisie loves
ed Sheeran and David and Dan had it as
like a surprise for her so they just had
they didn't tell her I told her by
accident I was like oh what's that
should be coming on the show but yeah
they kind of did it as a surprise
I was kind of mad cuz I've been talking
about B becoming on the show for a while
now but it's fine
I'm over it I've got a little bit of
backlash from the fans on Twitter for
appearing on Game of Thrones what do you
have to say about that you did
I thought you'd killed it ed Sheeran is
a hero no one no one Slade ed Sheeran
that's rude we had eg have a brand new
game of Thrones after show called
Westeros weekly and we have a running
segment called the Starks sister update
no.1 where each week we give an update
have they seen each other and then we
just made no no
that's amazing I like that can you give
us a Stark's sister update no I mean it
would be amazing if they were to cross
over at some point but I think we have
more chance in the Marvel Universe in
Game of Thrones because we're not about
happy endings I guess